bonjour à tous bienvenue pour les
questions d'actualité au sur public
sénat dans moins de quinze minutes place
donc à ces questions d'actualité nous
nous allons débattre pendant 15 minutes
de toute l'actualité parlementaire mais
aussi politique il ya beaucoup de choses
à dire avec deux sénatrices laurence
rossignol bonjour bonjour sénatrice de
l'oise ps porte parole du parti
socialiste face à vous catherine
procaccia sénatrice ump du val de marne
bonjour alors évidemment on va débattre
des retraites parce que c'est un texte
qu'on examine en ce moment même au sénat
les textes par prono vers 16h30 je vous
propose de rejoindre tentera nuit qui se
trouvent dans l'hémicycle pour nous
expliquer un peu et bien ce qu'il se
passe sur l'examen de ce texte et tam on
peut dire que le texte venue de
l'assemblée ne correspond plus du tout à
celui qui est en train d'être examiné
par le sénat effectivement bonjour
michael et bien depuis lundi soir les
sénateurs vide avec méthode la réforme
des retraites de sa substance c'est pour
çà et là ils ont trouvé une arme très
efficace et bien c'est l'amendement de
suppression c'est ainsi qu'ils ont
supprimée et bien l'article 2 d'abord
l'un des articles phares du texte qui
prévoit l'allongement progressif de la
durée de cotisation à 43 annuités pour
une retraite à taux plein puis ils ont
supprimé l'article 3 qui prévoyait
l'instauration d'un comité de
surveillance des retraites puis
l'article 4 qui prévoyait une
participation des retraités à l'effort
de financement des retraites et puis
dernière grosse suppression en date est
bien c'est la suppression du compte de
prévention de la pénibilité
un des grands apports de la réforme on
le voit donc bien les suppressions se
font en cascade je vous propose
d'écouter à ce propos le sénateur
écologiste jean desessard
l'article a été complètement transformé
l'article 2 a été supprimé l'article
trois a été supprimé l'article iv a été
supprimé l'article 5 lui par contre il a
été adopté et l'article 6 était supprimé
donc il va y avoir une commission mixte
paritaire
qui va analyser le projet de l'assemblée
nationale et notre article 5 et oui un
article sur six disait jean desessard ce
matin l'apport du sénat risque d'être
maigre ce travail de sape entre
guillemets du sénat n'est pas réellement
une surprise il faut dire qu'ici la
majorité de gauche est bien est très
fragile et très étroites il suffit qu'il
manque quelques voix écologistes ou bien
communiste pour qu'il y ait le rejet
d'un article et on s'avance donc très
certainement vers un rejet du texte ce
soir ou lundi donc par la suite il ya
très très peu de chances que députés et
sénateurs parviennent à un accord en
commission mixte paritaire et à la fin
et bien c'est l'assemblée nationale qui
aura le dernier mot et fin novembre
devrait donc revenir à une version
initiale du texte merci tam vous suivez
tout ça pour nous on se retrouve juste
avant les questions d'actu je reviendrai
vers vous avec d'autres questions d'eau
qu'on nous ici nous allons débattre et
bien totalement de l'aborder retraite si
vous le voulez bien il ya beaucoup
d'actualité vous avez entendu ce qu'il
se passe le texte qui vient de là sont
comme on aime en question
vous êtes toutes les deux sur ce texte
sur les retraites est justement vous
avez entendu ce que disait un thème
traduit à l'instant détricotage lmh
adresse tout d'abord au parti socialiste
évidemment parce qu'ils sont pour les
premiers concernés par ce détricotage de
ce texte ça vous surprend ou pas non
malheureusement ça me surprend pas mais
alors que ce texte est un texte qui à la
fois pérennise financièrement le système
de retraite et puis crée des avancées
nouvelles importantes en particulier ce
conte pénibilité des mesures pour
l'égalité des pensions entre les hommes
et les femmes on assiste à un travail
absolument désastreux au sénat je crois
que c'est encore plus désastreux pour le
sénat que pour les retraites veut dire
quoi c'est l'institution ce cénacle à je
pense que j'ai mis sur le devant de la
scène mais finalement
jusqu'au bout du compte le texte
reviendra à l'assemblée nationale et
l'assemblée nationale
ray adoptera un texte conforme à
l'intention du gouvernement et à la
majorité parlementaire mais ce qui se
passe au sénat c'est la coalition entre
ceux qui trouvent qu'un accroc dans ce
texte et ceux qui trouvent qu'un a pas
assez est ce là votre ensemble en gros
les différents groupes vote des
amendements de suppression etc ils
veulent tous ensemble résultats
effectivement
de d'article en article a plus de texte
à la fin à voter sur rien et abandonner
tout le travail du sol un moment donné
un moment donné ce que les gens vont se
poser comme question c'est à quoi sert
le sénat parce que défaire ce n'est pas
toujours faire mais en fait c'est votre
faute si on comprend bien non justement
justement ce qui est assez étonnant sur
ce texte puisque nous l'ump et les
centristes nous avons souvent été en
opposition contre des textes présentés
par le gouvernement c'est que là il ya
une coalition de la majorité
gouvernementale plus des communistes que
la majorité gouvernementale ne comprend
pas et en fonction des articles ya
vraiment toute la gauche hormis le ps
qui se trouve opposé à ce texte sur les
retraites ce qui est frappant c'est ça
c'est ce mécontentement au sein des gens
qui sont à gauche des gens qui sont
censés défendre le gouvernement est
aussi d un certain nombre de partis qui
font partie de la majorité fait que
finalement ce texte ne contente que le
parti socialiste il y aura eu il y aura
eu du temps pour analyser il y aurait eu
deux lectures pour analyser ce texte
nous on a passé trois semaines pour la
réforme fillon là on a cinq jours sept
jours il ya une seule lecture et bien je
crois que chacun exprime son
mécontentement ce mécontentement c'est
une faute de temps finalement c'est par
mécontentement sur le fond il n'ya pas
le problème de temps puisque la maladie
en 2035 année pour le par mais il ya
visiblement quelque chose qui se propage
dans le pays qui est assez étonnant
c'est que si j'entends ma collègue de
l'ump ce qui se passe dans l'hémicycle
ans on sait que les sénateurs expriment
leur mécontentement
c'est à dire qu'un peu comme les
manifestants breton les lycéens donc le
sénateur en fin de compte est
l'expression d'un mécontentement c'est
non les orateurs
l'affirmé son mécontentement mais
d'accord non le mécontentement d'un
sénateur il peut s'exprime par des
propositions constructives je m'étonne
quand même de la coalition de gens qui
sont supposés exprimé des positions
absolument opposés sur le système de
retraite les uns sont pour plus de
capitalisation les autres pour plus de
répartition mais néanmoins ils se
mettent d'accord pour empêcher d'avancer
donc ce qui se passe au sénat fait qu'un
jour les français vont se demander mais
à quoi sert le sénat si ce n'est à
défaire ce qui n'est pas bon jeu c'est
intéressant dans un institut ils ont
creusé elle-même sa tombe avec ses dents
avec autant d'obstination et de
constance et parce que vous dites madame
rossignol par rapport à l'institution
sénat je voudrais avoir votre réaction
baudouin prot question je suis pas
d'accord sur ce texte sur un certain
nombre de textes qu'on peut se poser des
questions mais ce n'est pas récent
puisque en 2011 lors des élections nous
avons eu un sénat qui était
majoritairement à gauche qui rejetait
absolument tous les textes proposés par
le gouvernement ou le sénat n'avait plus
son mot à dire donc il ya une culture de
la gauche au sénat depuis 2011 qui fait
que la gauche majoritaire dans la
majorité aux sénatoriales puis dans la
majorité au gouvernement refuse ce que
lui propose le gouvernement qui le
soutient je trouve ça assez étonnant
donc que je crains c'est que dans le
travail parlementaire et entre le
travail qui se fait entre les deux
assemblées le sénat était habituellement
respecté par l'assemblée nationale pour
la qualité de son travail de législateur
ont dû souvent seul le osé lancer le
fond c'est à une qualité trail
législateur ce qui permettait dans la
discussion bien que l'assemblée le
dernier mot d'arriver à obtenir des
avancées et à faire des textes de
compromis maintenant ce qui se passe
c'est que l'assemblée en garde de très
loin ce qui se passe au sénat de toute
façon il n'en sort rien donc
je ne sais pas je ne suis pas le
gouvernement la parole du parti
socialiste majoritaire il est très
difficile ensuite d'aller discuter avec
les députés en leur disant voilà nous
avons adopté des bons amendements on
vous demande tant en commission mixte
paritaire de les prendre en compte et
d'avancer de travailler ensemble bat
comment on regarde le sénat mais comme
une institution qui est un passage
obligé mais qui s'est mis dans une
logique de blocage et de deux
d'immobilisme tombe pas de travail
parlementaire est en train de
progressivement de se passer et on perd
la qualité du travail du sénat j'en suis
absolument désolé et vous êtes peut-être
aussi désolé pour les partis qui sont
aussi dans votre majorité je pense au
vert je pense à les communistes ne font
pas partie de votre majorité mais ce
sont quand même des alliés nous elle est
alliée aux municipales là quelque part
vous adressé aussi aux partis alliés
amis mais je constate que
l'individualisme est un vrai sujet dans
notre société à tous les échelons même
au parlement la somme des
individualismes n'arrive pas à faire une
orientation politique cohérente et
responsable alors sur ce texte pro
question simplement ajouté que si le
gouvernement faisait preuve d'un peu
plus d'ouverture
c'est à dire qu'il l'acceptait des
amendements y compris les amendements un
peu d'amendements de l'opposition
non madame rossignol parce que depuis un
an et demi on constate que même les
améliorations sont repoussées par le
gouvernement si le sénat faisait
auparavant un travail à un travail de
réflexion qui était reconnue c'est parce
que les gouvernements précédents et
j'étais rapporteur d'un certain nombre
de têtes on acceptait des amendements de
l'opposition qui nous paraissait aller
dans le bon sens là il ya un refus
général pour l'opposition on s'y est
habitué mais je pense que votre majorité
ne s'y habitue pas parce qu'au bout du
compte le texte est rejeté ce qui rend
très difficile
il est rejeté par
les retraites on l'a vécu sur d'autres
textes précédemment au bout du compte on
peut toujours faire tout le travail
qu'on veut le tsv trop jeter encore une
coédition ceux qui sont contre pour des
raisons différentes de la commission
mixte paritaire entre l'assemblée et le
sénat pour décider finalement de ce
texte sur les retraites le sénat devra
rien gagné ne pourra hélas on ne sait
pas si un texte sera voté ou pas voté
pour l'instant au seigneur c'est lundi
soir que ça se passera je n'ai aucune
idée puisque à chacun les articles nous
opposition connaissons notre position
mais on connaît pas celle de la majorité
sénatoriale et présidentielle alors
voilà ça c'était pour le sénat pour tous
les aspects sur les retraites je
voudrais évidemment vous entendre sur
l'actualité politique et l'actualité
politique ce matin elle a été dominée
par une déclaration de marine le pen à
propos des ex otages qui sont arrivés
hier à paris je vous propose d'écouter
la députée européenne présidente du
front national est évidemment réagi
juste après
c'est ce qu'ont ressenti beaucoup de
français s'est passé là-bas qui vous en
avez l'impression d'avoir des images de
dom qui était
très réservé c'est le moins qu'on puisse
dire les deux qui portait la barbe
taillée d'une manière qui était tout de
même assez
étonnante les l'habillement est étrange
enfin
des sanctions bien sûr bien sûr monsieur
mais cet otage avec paul pas bien passé
jusqu'à le le chèche sur le visage tout
ça voilà je pense que ça mérite
peut-être quelques explications de leur
part parce que c'est vrai que ça allait
c'est je crois une impression étrange
aux français pour la déclaration de
marine le pen ce matin chez nos
confrères de repas à la une du monde je
voudrais juste vous livrer ce titre le
dérapage de marine le pen laurence
rossignol porte parole du parti
socialiste
c'est un dérapage bien sûr c'est un
dérapage c'était quelqu'un d'autre on
pourrait prendre ça avec humour et dire
je crois qu'ils regardent trop de séries
télévisées et qu'ils ont trop vu
homeland et ses histoires de tâches qui
sont retournés par les parts par les
ravisseurs mais le problème avec les le
pen c'est la constance dans l'incapacité
à tenir longtemps les tentatives de
respectabilité mais marine le pen a
essayé d'être de devenir une femme
politique respectable comme son père a
essayé de le faire dans le passé et
pietrus a abandonné ou leurs efforts
s'effondre devant la réalité de ce
qu'ils sont ce qu'ils sont c'est à dire
la haine la peur de l'autre la volonté
de toujours stigmatisé de dénoncer et de
traquer partout le musulman l'étranger
l'autre et la marine le pen vient de
rentrer dans le rang de la famille le
pen de ses grandes déclarations
honteuses indigne d'une vraie sa
politique française elle est une digne
héritière de la famille le pen ce matin
on peut dire aussi peut-être que c'est
une question de stratégie être au centre
de la question politique c'est peut-être
ça et que les médias lui donne
naturellement la parole la première page
du journal vous trouvez pas
moi je pense que madame le pen aurait
passé trois ans en détention elle
s'exprimerait peut-être pas comme ça
mais je pense qu'effectivement lui
consacrer une première page sur des
déclarations qui sont ridicules
ça ne mérite pas de consacrer du temps
politique merci beaucoup merci d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je voudrais
qu'on allait retrouver dans l'hémicycle
tam traduit parce que le président du
sénat est en train d'arriver sur le
plateau pour l'hémicycle dans tout de
suite les questions d'actualité cette
âme tran huy est-ce que vous pouvez nous
dire un peu comment ça va se passer
aujourd'hui oui il va écouter on peut
noter certaines questions qui doit s
annonce déjà marre quand il va ya voir
françois noël buffet sénateur ump du
rhône qui interrogera manuel valls sur
les roms le ministre de l'intérieur sera
dans l'hémicycle pour lui répondre
directement manuel valls qui répondra
également à une question de l'ump michel
savin sur les crédits de la gendarmerie
ça c'est une question sur laquelle il ya
beaucoup d'attentes à laquelle le
ministre de l'intérieur a déjà
partiellement répondu ce matin en
annonçant le déblocage de 111 millions
d'euros pour la police et la gendarmerie
à noter également une question de leila
aichi sénatrice écologiste qu'il a posé
une question sur la défense des ong
environnementales
on pense bien sûr à la situation de
greenpeace en russie alors que jean marc
ayrault le premier ministre est
actuellement en russie greenpeace qui a
fait une action sur une plate-forme
pétrolière de gazprom et dont 30
militants dont un français sont
actuellement emprisonnés en russie il y
aura également une question de michel le
scouarnec sur la bretagne mais tout de
suite place à la séance en
absolument au tam vous avez tout dit
place à la séance des questions
d'actualité des questions d'actualité au
gouvernement
je rappelle deux minutes trente pour
l'auteur de la question et pour la
réponse
la parole est à monsieur aymeri de
montesquiou pour le groupe udi uc
monsieur le président mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse au
ministre de la réforme de l'état
face au déficit budgétaire chacun doit
participer la baisse des dépenses y
compris les territoires or l'état ne
s'appliquent pas l'effort qui leur
demandent en effet entre 2013 et 2015
les dotations aux collectivités
territoriales baisseront de 3 6% alors
que les dépenses de l'état augmenteront
de 2 % elles passeront de 299 milliards
et demi à 305 25 milliards l'effort que
vous demandez aux petites communes
rurales n'est pas soutenable ces
communes ont des ressources extrêmement
faibles ou les dotations tiennent une
place majeure leurs dépenses de
fonctionnement notamment salariales sont
quasi incompressible elle se résume à
une secrétaire de mairie et un employé
communal quelques heures par semaine
le maire ne recevant que l'indemnité
symbolique lorsque vous dites que la
baisse des notations ne correspondra
qu'à une moyenne de 0 69% par
collectivité c'est inexact la part
communale forfaitaire de la dgf
supportera plus de 800 millions d'euros
de réductions soient plus de 4% par
rapport à l'an passé
un tel niveau de contraction ni la
péréquation ni la dotation de solidarité
rurale ne suffiront à la compenser
de plus vous avez déclaré que vous ne
pouviez pas engager l'état sur la fin de
la réduction des dotations c'est un
signal très négatif pour les projets
d'investissement que vous dites vouloir
préserver madame la ministre on ne peut
demander plus à des communes déjà
exemple vous devez fixer un plancher
protecteur pour les petites communes
rurales vous devez mettre en place comme
cela suffit fait en 2011 par le fonds
national de péréquation des ressources
intercommunales et communales une
réforme des dotations par stratification
madame le ministre la baisse de la dgf
ne pourrait-elle pas s'effectuer par
strate de population et de budget de
fonctionnement
je vous le demande avec insistance ne
condamnait pas les petites communes
rurales
merci pour vous répandre madame marylise
lebranchu ministre de la réforme de
l'état de la décentralisation de la
fonction publique merci monsieur le
président monsieur la mairie de
montescot merci de votre question je ne
partage pas votre analyse mais vous
l'avez déjà dit tout à l'heure je
voudrais quand même rappeler à un
certain nombre de faire important
effectivement un milliard et demi de
suppression c'est alors je n'ai pas dit
c'était 0 69 % de moyenne dit que cédé 0
69% des dotations il faut pas que
oublier que les chiffres des dotations
de l'état dépasse les 80 milliards que
si vous prenez le tout avec ce que nous
avons fait comme effort + 4 % pour le
déçu puisque 4% aussi pour la dsr ça
rejoint vos préoccupations
nous ne sommes pas -0 69 % pour la
moyenne des collectivités rurales non
plus première chose il fallait
participer à l'effort nous sommes treize
ans de ça et vous le savez parce que
nous avons eu déjà ces débats dans
différentes enceintes les propositions
qui étaient faites y compris par madame
pécresse lors de la passation de pouvoir
qui était d'enlever 5 milliards par an
n'ont pas été suivies par le président
de la république qui a tenu à être aussi
précis que possible dans une
participation des collectivités
territoriales mais inférieure à celle de
l'état donc vous avez eu en grande
partie satisfaction puisque nous avons
certains diraient reculé sur la baisse
des dotations des collectivités
territoriales mais tout ça pour protéger
nos communes nous avons également décidé
je lui disais
en filigrane de première partie
d'aider davantage les communes qui
avaient des difficultés à travers la dsu
les desserts il faut pas oublier c'est +
4 % nous avons et vous l'avez dit nous
avons également effectivement vous même
si vous n'êtes pas tout à fait d'accord
avec notre lecture des choses
préserver la péréquation nous l'avons
augmenté parce que il faut être auprès
au maximum des collectivités les plus
pauvres et vous dites les collectivités
rurales je voudrais juste dire ici et
c'est très important que nous en soyons
d'accord c'est qu'il ya des communautés
rurales en très très grande difficulté
des communautés rurales qui se porte
correctement donc nous ne pouvons pas
non plus faire une cote unique pour
toutes nos communautés de communes
rurales où nos communautés de communes
aura donc ce que je voudrais vous dire
c'est outre le fait qu'on a
persuadé les uns et les autres de faire
un effort sur la péréquation qui a été
voté à l'assemblée nationale et ici il
n'y a aucun souci nous avons également
posé la question de la dgf et de la
péréquation verticale
vous avez raison sur ce point nous
n'arrêtons pas d'année en année je mets
de côté les dégâts de la réforme de la
taxe professionnelle devenue cvae que
nous partageons tous et nous essayons de
les pallier si jamais cela de côté nous
essayons de nous reposer la question de
ces péréquation d'année en année aligne
et je pense que la remise à plat de la
dgf et la prise en compte par exemple
des mètres carrés agricoles des mètres
carrés de protection des captages de
tout ça est important et ensemble ce que
nous y arriverons merci la parole à
notre collègue françois patriat pour le
groupe socialiste merci monsieur le
président mesdames messieurs les
ministres ma question s'adresse aussi à
madame lebranchu en l'absence de
monsieur sapin il ya quatre cent
quarante mille apprentis en france
l'apprentissage est une des voies de la
réussite elle permet à beaucoup de
jeunes d'accéder à l'emploi pour des
conditions que les entreprises demandent
aujourd'hui et recherche les régions
sont pleinement compétente dans le
domaine de l'apprentissage et elles
entendent assumer cette compétence plus
encore dans un contexte un peu d'ici fut
difficile contexte de la crise bien
entendu contexte de la difficulté pour
retrouver des recruteurs d'apprentis
dans le projet de loi de finances il ya
une mesure qui vise demain à faire en
sorte que seules les entreprises de
moins de dix salariés puissent accéder à
la prime pour l'apprentissage c'est une
mesure que nous acceptons difficilement
mais que l'on peut comprendre compte
tenu que ce sont pour la plupart et que
les grandes entreprises chers collègues
peuvent avoir moins de difficulté à
recruter les apprentis mais par contre
concernant une partie des fonds de la
taxe d'apprentissage pas que j'ai c'est
une nébuleuse aujourd'hui qui mérite
d'être réformé il ya une partie de ces
fonds qui doit être sanctuarisé parce
qu'elle est d entreprise l aide des
associations l aide des jeunes notamment
les jeunes décrocheurs qui vont vers
l'emploi et nous attendons donc du
gouvernement que ces deux parties soient
sanctuarisés mais ma question se
tournent plutôt vers l'avenir celles qui
veulent la réussite de l'apprentissage
et pour ce faire j'ai proposé en
commission des finances avec mes
collègues de la commission des finances
une réforme à la fois de la collecte et
de la répartition de cette taxe
d'apprentissage
il ya trois pistes dans ces dossiers
mesure la première est de diminuer le
nombre d'organismes collecteurs car il
ya aujourd'hui une nébuleuse
d'organismes collecteurs avec des
déperditions d'argent en ligne sur les
deux milliards 4 de la prime
d'apprentissage il y a d'autre part une
un nouveau modèle de répartition avec
une fusion des différentes taxes qui
pourrait arriver à permettre de cibler
mieux l'objectif je le crois de
gouvernements et de cibler mieux vers
l'apprentissage niveau 4 niveau 5 les
moyens qui sont ainsi récoltées alors ma
question est double madame la ministre
entend à haut niveau avec les régions de
france que vous connaissez bien bien
avec l'ensemble du des gens intéressés
par l'apprentissage est ce que la partie
qui va continuer d'aider les centres
d'apprentis soit bien sanctuariser et
que devant la future réforme de la taxe
d'apprentissage qui va intervenir dans
un texte futures soient bien prises en
compte cette simplification se
paritarisme qui doit être demain établie
et que les régions puissent participer
demain à la réforme de l'attribution de
la taxe d'apprentissage je vous remercie
merci madame marylise lebranchu
merci monsieur des présidents michel
sapin aurait souhaité répondre et au
fond je réponds pratiquement avec sylvia
pinel qui est aussi au coeur de ces
sujets parce que le gouvernement s'est
fixé au sein du pacte de croissance la
compétitivité et l'emploi l'objectif de
faire progresser le nombre d'apprentis
vous l'avez rappelé de 435 milles 9 en
2012 à 500 milles en 2017 et à cette fin
il a déjà pris un certain nombre
d'initiatives telles que le
renouvellement des développeurs de
l'apprentissage vous avez fait allusion
l'accélération du programme des
investissements d'avenir consacré à la
formation et à l'hébergement des
apprentis on a trop souvent oublié et
nous proposons en ce moment même au
parlement d'améliorer de façon
substantielle les droits à la retraite
des apprentis dans le cadre du projet de
loi garantissant l'avenir et la justice
du système de retraites il avait aussi
été oublié une étape d'une plus grande
ampleur sera vous avez raison franchi à
travers une réforme plus globale de
l'apprentissage et de son financement au
terme d'une première phase de
concertation conduite par michel sapin
ministre du travail de l'emploi de la
formation professionnelle et du dialogue
social avec des grands acteurs de
l'apprentissage les partenaires sociaux
les régions où les chambres consulaires
avec également sylvia pinel le
gouvernement vient de rendre public les
axes principaux de cette réforme ils
sont d'ailleurs cher sénateur patriat
pour la plupart cohérent avec des
conclusions de votre rapport
d'information dont tout le monde tient à
saluer la très bonne qualité
notre volonté est d'orienter davantage
les ressources des retards bien le sens
pas le financement de l'apprentissage
et je vous dis la substance du rapport
simplifier le dispositif de collecte de
la taxe d'apprentissage en réduisant le
nombre d'organismes collecteurs vous
avez raison et vous serez suivi
renforcer le dialogue social et
territorial en vue de la répartition de
cet axe sécuriser le parcours de
formation des apprentis et dans ce
nouveau dispositif
les régions compétentes sur le champ de
l'apprentissage depuis les premières
lois de décentralisation seront
confortées ou le viol y ait ce sera fait
dans leur rôle à la fois de financement
et de régulation leurs moyens seront
renforcés dans leur dynamisme
conformément aux engagements pris
toujours dans ce pacte de confiance et
dans ce but une part de la taxe
d'apprentissage sera régionalisée et
sans produits répartis selon des règles
favorable au développement de
l'apprentissage lui-même en outre une
concertation sera organisée entre les
régions les organismes collecteurs sur
la répartition des fonds libres et cela
afin d'articuler hobby au mieux les
politiques de développement de
l'alternance des branches et des
territoires et cette réforme d'ampleur
nous la voulons dès le 1er janvier 2015
c'est patriat comme l'ensemble des
sénateurs nous comptons sur vous pour
nous accompagner merci la parole et à
madame là il a agi pour le groupe
écologiste
ma question s'adresse à monsieur laurent
fabius ministre des affaires étrangères
depuis six semaines l'équipage de
l'arctic sunrise navire de l'omg
greenpeace est en détention provisoire
dans la prison la prison de mourmansk en
russie leur crime avoir dénoncé de
manière non-violente les projets de
forage de la société gazprom au delà du
cercle polaire pouvons-nous madame la
ministre laisser condamner les citoyens
ce lanceur d' alerte au motif qu'il
refuse le saccage de l'article bien
évidemment non l'arctique abrite un
écosystème fragile et unique au monde
avec de nombreux espaces protégés en
voie de disparition et ô combien
nécessaire au devenir de l'humanité plus
grave encore en trente ans la surface
recouverte par la banquise est passé
d'une superficie moyenne de 6,5 à 3,4
millions de kilomètres carrés soit une
diminution équivalente à près de cinq
fois la superficie totale de la france
or parce qu'elle réfléchisse les
rayonnements solaires et contribuent
directement la régulation des
températures la disparition de la
banquise serait un point de non retour
pour le réchauffement climatique avec
pour conséquence la montée du niveau des
eaux et l'acidification des océans qui
aura nécessairement un impact sur les
ressources halieutiques l'arctique
renfermerait 22% des rêveurs des
réserves mondiales en hydrocarbures
faisant l'objet d'un sinistre d'une
sinistre convoitises de la part des
groupes pétroliers et miniers plus grave
encore l'accroissement inéluctable et
stress environnementaux et énergétiques
dans cette région du monde seront à
terme la source de tensions et de
conflits point que nous autres
écologistes plaident ont à travers le
concept de la green différence alors que
dans deux semaines militaire
internationale débattre à varsovie des
moyens de faire face au réchauffement
climatique le premier ministre
actuellement à moscou ne peut ignorer
les activités néfastes pour
l'environnement des groupes pétroliers
et notamment gazprom poids lourds de
l'industrie russe il semblerait qu'il
ait prévu d'évoquer ce sujet avec les
autorités russes dont acte il est
impératif que notre diplomatie ruse de
toute son influence pour libérer les
trente prisonniers et impulser un nouvel
élan international en faveur d'une
convention maritime mieux adaptées aux
problématiques d'aujourd'hui
l'article madame la ministre ne doit pas
être un enjeu géoéconomique salah
sanctuarise la sanctuarisation de cette
zone permettra à terme de contrer les
risques inhérents comme les marées
noires à l'exploitation massive des
matières premières et à la pêche
industrielle et ainsi pallier les
insuffisances de la convention de
montego bay madame la ministre devant
l'indifférence coupable des nations et
du dramatique silence de l'onu et de
l'europe les ong environnementales
mènent parfois au péril de leur vie une
action essentielle pour le bien-être des
générations futures et la survie de
l'humanité alors que les 32 l'arctique
ont d'abord été injustement qualifiées
de terroristes de pirate de hooligans de
vandales ses militants sont en réalité
des héros oui des héros au même titre
que chico mendes morts pour la défense
de l'amazonie du capitaine watson de law
and the sea shepherd sous le coup d'un
mandat d'arrêt international pour sa
lutte contre la paire sino choco légal
j'ai fini et que vous avez ignoré madame
la ministre quel sera votre action pour
libérer les transférer de l'office
comment la france peut-elle protéger ses
lanceurs d'alert internationaux à
commencer par le capitaine palois depuis
six ans crêpés remercie l'onda droit
international et d'un statut de réfugié
politique et commercy pour vous répondre
la dame najat vallaud belkacem
porte-parole du gouvernement merci
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice aïchi marting sunrise a été
arraisonné il y a maintenant plus d'un
mois en effet par les autorités russes
et ce sont trente militants de
greenpeace qui étaient à son bord et qui
sont depuis lors en détention en
détention préventive dans la ville de
mourmansk pas remis figure 1 nos
compatriotes francisco pisani et la
france lui a immédiatement accordé la
protection consulaire et je veux vous
assurer que nous suivons avec la plus
grande attention les développements de
cette affaire le premier ministre comme
vous le savez est en ce moment même en
russie ne m'appartient pas vous nous le
comprendre et de d'évoquer à sa place sa
visite mais ce que je peux vous dire
avec certitude c'est que le gouvernement
est pleinement mobilisés sur cette
affaire il agit de la façon la plus
efficace possible dans l'intérêt de
notre compatriote en particulier ces
questions font partie de la politique
étrangère de la france dans tous les
déplacements en russie comme dans les
autres pays les autorités françaises les
évoque avec franchise et en même temps
dans le respect des interlocuteurs parce
que je crois que c'est en créant les
conditions du dialogue en examinant
posément la situation notamment de notre
compatriote qu'on pourra apporter une
réponse concrète à ce problème
s'agissant du sujet de fond que vous
évoquez à savoir la question de
l'exploitation des ressources naturelles
en arctique vous savez qu'elle fait
aujourd'hui l'objet de débats au sein du
conseil article sachez que en tant
qu'observateurs au sein de ce conseil la
france compte bien prendre toute sa part
à ce débat je vous remercie
merci la parole est à présent michel le
scouarnec pour le groupe crc
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le premier ministre maintenant
la milice vallaud belkacem depuis plus
d'un an la bretagne est saigné soumise à
un véritable désastre économique et
social dans cette déroute en bretagne
est loin d'être la seule région frappée
par ce système à bout de souffle qui
conduit à la faillite d'entreprises et
aux licenciements massifs et souvent
abusifs
ce que vous appelez la compétitivité
représente pour nos concitoyens une
réalité tragique à l'opposé d'une visée
humaniste au regard du contexte actuel
la non de la suspension de l'application
de l'écotaxe sur l'ensemble du
territoire national était la seule
décision adaptée face à l'urgence
sociale et la cristallisation des
mobilisations et des tensions pour
autant l'éco taxe ne doit pas être
rejeté par principe sa mise en oeuvre
doit s'inscrire dans une réflexion
globale sur la transition écologique des
territoires par le développement du
ferroutage la relocalisation des modes
de production et de distribution
un grand débat sur les coûts du
transport s'impose mais cette volonté
est loin d'être évidente pour la
bretagne d'autant plus que vous avez
annoncé le non financement de la ligne
de chemin de fer brest quimper rennes
comment alors dans ces conditions
changer les pratiques vers les nouvelles
infrastructures de transport si l'état
ne compte pas les moyens suffisants pour
les créer toutefois l'écotaxe n'est pas
la seule cause de la crise du monde
agricole et du modèle économique breton
au nom des seuls signaux du marché les
entreprises se livrent à la plus
farouche concurrence du coût du travail
et des cours agricoles les plus bas
seuls les actionnaires sans grèce alors
que les milliers de salariés soient
abandonnés à leur sort il n'y a pas de
fatalité aux politiques d'austérité de
chômage de masse de dumping social des
conséquences désastreuses de la loi lme
et des tentatives de contractualisation
plus favorable aux grands distributeurs
coproducteur ils sont engagé la bataille
de la réindustrialisation
agroalimentaire son avenir et une
nouvelle ambition agricole passe par la
juste rémunération du travail des
salariés et dépaysant et bien soutenir
des filières de production
relocaliser pour s'en sortir il faut
d'urgence une autre voie le gouvernement
doit s'opposer aux licenciements
boursiers mettre en place de nouveaux
systèmes de régulation mais surtout et
prioritairement mener une réforme
fiscale d'envergure mettant la justice
et l'équité au centre de notre fiscalité
la bretagne veut vivre quelles mesures
comptez-vous mettre en oeuvre dans les
prochains mois pour que la bretagne
retrouvent espoir en l'avenir merci
madame najat vallaud belkacem
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
sénateur le scouarnec merci de cette
question qui porte sur un sujet donc
vous savez que il est notre première
préoccupation le premier ministre
réunissait encore mardi dernier les élus
de bretagne c'était une réunion
exceptionnelle associant à la fois les
parlementaires mais aussi les élus de la
région et du département réunis à
matignon une réunion exceptionnelle
parce que la situation était
exceptionnelle et vous en étiez je vous
en remercie la bretagne c'est une région
dynamique qui dispose de nombreux atouts
traverse aujourd'hui une crise une crise
en particulier dans le secteur de
l'agroalimentaire le gouvernement s'est
mobilisé dès le début et a pris
l'initiative je pense en particulier à
la situation que nous avons trouvé à
doubs ou encore dans le groupe gad le 12
septembre dernier le premier ministre a
annoncé à un plan agroalimentaire pour
la bretagne il a également annoncé des
mesures d'urgence des moyens financiers
immédiatement disponibles notamment pour
accompagner les salariés de ces
entreprises et les entreprises les plus
touchées
aujourd'hui nos objectifs sont simples
préserver l'emploi redonner des
perspectives économiques à la région le
16 octobre dernier jean marc ayrault a
proposé une deuxième étape dans la
mobilisation avec le pacte d'avenir pour
la bretagne qui a pour priorité de
moderniser l'appareil productif un
contrat de plan etat-région anticipé a
été annoncée qui est déjà en préparation
entre le préfet de région et les élus du
territoire force est de constater
aujourd'hui que ce travail nécessite
d'être collectif et que c'est ce qui
fera la force de la bretagne or ce
travail a été bloqué en effet vous
l'avez dit par un sujet l'écotaxe ce
projet qui avait été votée en 2009 conçu
par l'ancienne majorité préparé par
l'ancien gouvernement dans la mise en
oeuvre avait déjà été reporté une fois
preuve des difficultés qu'elles posent
et chacun sait ici que l'écotaxe n'est
pas la cause de la crise de
l'agroalimentaire en bretagne mais
indéniablement elle soulève des
questions de mise en oeuvre qui n'ont
pas été anticipées par le gouvernement
précédent alors le gouvernement actuel a
déjà corrigé certains effets négatifs de
cette écotaxe mais à l'évidence ça
n'était pas suffisant
c'est la raison pour laquelle le premier
ministre a choisi de recréer les
conditions d'un dialogue constructif
dans la région en suspendant la mise en
oeuvre de cette écotaxe ce dialogue
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs il
devra associer toutes les bonnes
volontés je sais qu'elles sont
nombreuses je vous remercie monsieur le
sénateur d'en faire partie
merci monsieur gilbert barbier pour le
groupe rds
tout seul président mesdames messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresse au ministre de
l'économie et des finances mais il voit
là pourtant il avait avait beaucoup de
raisons au mois d'août mis en garde
contre le ras-le-bol fiscale et le
président de la république avait répondu
en prenant avec une promesse de pause
n'est aujourd'hui plus personne n'y
croit
après les énormes sacrifices qu'ont été
demandée l'an dernier les ménages vont
être vous avoir à payer 12 milliards de
plus en 2014
le premier moteur de la croissance et la
confiance et la confiance supposant un
cap une certaine stabilité
or il n'est pas une semaine soit que
vous inventer un nouvel impôt ou que
vous changez les règles du jeu ou ne
concluent aussi les revirements où les
volte-face comme sur la taxe sur le
diesel date actionnaires le b e la tva
réduite sur les produits de première
nécessité la tâte de 75% la fiscalité
sur l'épargné et avant-hier l'écotaxe
comment voulez vous que nos concitoyens
vous fassent confiance au mécontentement
des retraités salariés consommateurs
s'ajoute celui des quelque 170 mille
frontaliers résidant en france et
travaillant en suisse ils ont été que
j'ai un millier à défiler il ya quelques
jours devant l'assemblée nationale et
dans les villes notamment une ville de
pontarlier comme seul me soit de
l'économie connaît bien puisque c'est
son département pour défendre le droit
d'option dont ils bénéficient en matière
d'assurance maladie
comme vous le savez celui ci arrive à
échéance en mai 2014 malgré l'appel des
élus des zones frontalières de franche
comté mais aussi d'alsace de l'ain de la
haute savoie vous avez décidé de ne pas
proroger ce dispositif au nom de
l'égalité de tous au regard des droits
sociaux mais de quelle égalité s'agit-il
alors que ces personnes travaillent dans
un pays où le droit du travail est bien
moins protecteur que le nôtre où ils
surent porte des contraintes liées aux
déplacements au logement aux congés et
de plus demain il leur en coûtera
environ le double d'aujourd'hui pour
être assurés contre le risque de maladie
soit environ 150 à 250 euros par mois de
prélèvements en leur imposant
d'abandonner leurs assurances privées
pour rejoindre le régime de sécurité
sociale vous faites un choix idéologique
qui de surcroît pour eux pose la
question de la poursuite des soins
engagés en suisse quelles réponses
pouvez vous apporter à toucher
frontaliers qui ne demande qu'une chose
c'est de ne pas les décourager d'aller
au travail
merci madame michèle delaunay ministre
chargée des personnes âgées et de
l'autonomie sénateurs monsieur le
président monsieur le sénateur un bar
gay je vous demande tout d'abord tout ce
que peut bien vouloir excuser de l'amour
est un bouquet départ qui ne peux pas
vous répondre dans le temps restant vous
avez raison jusqu alors les frontaliers
ont eu à bénéficier d'un droit d'option
entre assurance maladie française où ces
assurances privées ce droit d'option est
en réversible certains d'entre eux
d'ailleurs cette adresse est à
l'assurance privée quand il faisait déjà
des bien portants pour revenir vers
l'assurance maladie française quand ils
étaient plus âgés ceux qui
contreviennent bien évidemment à nos
valeurs al'inverse sa chose aussi que la
deux a été radié de l'assurance privée
alors qu'il venait d'être atteint d'un
concert paraît qu'il était encore très
jeune et il a appelé ses congénères à ne
pas à retourner vers l'assurance
française
donc je vous rappelle aussi et vous le
savez bien évidemment que l'agenda de
cette non de cette absence de droits
d'options a été fixé par le gouvernement
de droite de la majorité précédente
c'est vrai en tout cas c'est vous qui en
avez
je n'ai pas parlé de faute mais vous en
avez fixé l'agenda
l'agenda est donc nous nous sommes de
notre côté cantonné à
améliorer les conditions de cette
transition et c'est ainsi qu'un tarif
dégressif a été mis en place qui est de
seulement à une cotisation de seulement
6 % la première année et 8 % la seconde
ce qui permet à 50% des frontaliers 3500
jurassien qui vous sont chers de ne pas
débourser un euro de plus et dans la
période suivante de taille de dames de
table d'avoir un tarif de cotisation
raisonnable d'autre part et je tiens le
signaler contrairement à ce que vous
avez affirmé madame touraine a pris
l'engagement formel que tous les
patients qui auraient commencé un
traitement en suisse un traitement lourd
en suisse pourront le continuer sans
aucun problème d'autre part vous le
savez ce droit d'option était anti quo
anticonstitutionnel et à l'est en
contravention des valeurs qui ont
présidé à la mise en place de
l'assurance maladie à la française merci
la parole est à présent notre collègue
françois noël buffet pour le groupe e
ump
monsieur le président ma question est à
l'attention de monsieur le ministre de
l'intérieur
dans le département du rhône le préfet
vient de prendre une décision de
réquisition d'un terrain situé sur la
commune d'oullins afin d'y installer 300
demandeurs d'asile expulsés de la ville
de lyon à la suite d'une procédure
d'expulsion engagée par le maire de lyon
président du grand lyon
le terrain qui a été choisi et sur une
commune qui est petit 26 mille habitants
un petit territoire en politique de la
ville de surcroît accueillant déjà 225
demandeurs d'asile depuis longtemps
sur son cul sur son territoire
l'émotion est extrêmement grande d'abord
parce que la pression migratoire sur
département du rhône est extrêmement
forte ensuite parce que les habitants se
sont mobilisés fortement contre la
manière dont cette décision a été prise
plus de six mille pétitionnaires
aujourd'hui pour une commune de 26 mille
habitants vous conviendrez que les
choses sont importantes
au plan national nous savons que la
demande d'asile est en augmentation une
augmentation très forte le rapport du
sénateur karoutchi indique même que pour
2013 nous serons à plus de 70 mille
demandes nous savons également que
l'ofpra ne rend pas les décisions avec
la cour nationale du droit d'asile dans
un délai inférieur à 19 mois aujourd'hui
ce qui est considérable je tiens à
souligner que si le précédent
gouvernement on était arrivé à
redescendre entre neuf et dix mois
je voudrais monsieur le ministre attirer
votre attention sur le fait que le
problème tient à plusieurs choses
d'abord la difficulté de définir ce
qu'est un pays d'origine sûrs et la
difficulté surtout d'avoir une
définition commune à l'échelle de
l'europe ça c'est le premier point le
deuxième point c'est que ces délais
d'instruction étant tellement long qu'il
favorise évidemment les filières
d'immigration clandestine qui souhaitent
profiter de l'occasion pour pouvoir
maintenir sur le territoire des gens qui
ne relèvent pas du droit d'asile auquel
nous sommes tous d'ailleurs attaché
enfin il faut rappeler que sur les
années précédentes sur les 53000
décision de d'expulsion du territoire
seules vingt mille sont exécutés les
autres restant sur le territoire
national nous produisons donc comme l'a
remarqué également notre collègue
brassaï notre collègue karoutchi nous
mêmes nos propres situation irrégulière
alors monsieur le ministre j'ai trois
questions pour le rhône pouvez-vous
intervenir auprès du préfet pour qu'il
le modifie sa décision qu'il revienne
sur sa décision et qu'on puisse
reconsidérer la situation telle qu'elle
est aujourd'hui et tel quel les crée
aujourd'hui au plan national ne
serait-il pas opportun monsieur le
ministre d'envoyer des représentants de
l'ofpra en albanie notamment pour
peut-être analysé sur place
immédiatement les demandes d'asile qui
pourrait être déposée enfin quelles
mesures allez vous engager pour qu'on
ait une définition unitaire en europe
deux pays d'origine sûrs et bien sûr
quel moyen pour exécuter les décisions
de retour merci merci monsieur manuel
valls ministre de l'intérieur
c'est le président mesdames et messieurs
les sénateurs monsieur le le sénateur
buffet vous avez rappelé d'abord une
situation qui est très tendue et c'est
vrai en rhône alpes et dans le
département du rhône la région
rhône-alpes a connu une hausse de plus
de 50% du nombre de demandeurs d'asile
dans le département du rhône ce nombre a
doublé et c'est vrai que lyon et le
grand lyon sont impactés cette situation
critique ce n'est pas le seul
département qui connaissent la connu une
saturation des capacités d'hébergement
ce sont cinq mille sept cents personnes
qui sont hébergés chaque jour par l'état
et le préfet c'est son devoir veille à
la répartition sur l'ensemble du
département mais malgré ses efforts
conséquents il n'est pas possible de
trouver des solutions d'hébergement pour
tous et si ce temps les solutions à la
veille de l'hiver particulièrement
difficile la capacité d'accueil dans le
rhône sera augmenté de 900 places durant
la période hivernale c'est pourquoi le
préfet a décidé mais je peux en dire un
mode hébergé sur un terrain de votre
commune
290 demandeurs d'asile qui occupaient
depuis le début juillet 2013 une zone à
côté de la gare de lyon perrache sous un
autopont avec près de 100 enfants dans
des conditions terribles j'ai pu moi
même le voir de mes yeux il y a quelques
jours depuis 2011 d'autres communes dont
la vôtre de l'agglomération lyonnaise
ont participé à cet effort collectif
d'hébergement mais il est évident que
nous ne tiendrons pas très longtemps et
que ce type de solution par rapport au
terrain doullens j'ai demandé je vais
demander aux préfets d'organiser
autrement la répartition je vous connais
bien je ne doute pas que vous
participerez à cet effort mais nous
allons faire en sorte que cet accueil de
ces populations soient organisés
autrement et j'en prends auprès de vous
l'engagement pour ce qui concerne la
réforme du droit d'asile elle est en
cours depuis plusieurs mois avec une
concertation qui est menée par valérie
létard et jean louis tourenne notamment
pour réduire les délais il était autour
de 20 mois sous le gouvernement
précédent aujourd'hui nous essayons de
le ramener à 16 mois et l'objectif c'est
évidemment neuf mois mais c'est
difficile il faut des moyens nous les
avons donné à l'ofpra
c'est toute la procédure qui doit être
revue pour réduire les délais au niveau
national dans une concertation au niveau
européen et avec une organisation
beaucoup plus directif pour ce qui
concerne l'accueil sur notre territoire
j'espère et je conclus avec cela
monsieur le sénateur que nous arrivons
est ce mon souhait à une proposition
consensuelle parce que sur ce sujet là
nous avons besoin qu'au niveau national
comme au niveau local nous trouvions les
voies d'un consensus pour régler ce
problème de l'asile et notamment du sort
des déboutés du droit d'asile
merci l'apparent l'état monsieur yannick
vaugrenard pour le groupe socialiste
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
ma question s'adresse à monsieur benoît
hamon ministre délégué auprès du
ministre de l'économie des finances
je souhaite monsieur le ministre vous
interroger sur la situation d'une
industrie forte et emblématique dans
notre pays à savoir la construction
navale les chantiers de saint nazaire en
loire atlantique ont su construire le
normandie le france le queen mary 2 et
des buts depuis quelques semaines
la construction du plus grand navire de
croisière du monde l'oasis 3 par
ailleurs la diversification est bien
présente avec le développement en
particulier de l'éolien offshore la
qualité de la main d'oeuvre est donc
mondialement reconnu et apprécié par
contre ce qui est source d'inquiétude
aujourd'hui et le fait que l'actionnaire
à 66 6 % de ce chantier stx france à
savoir la principale banque publique de
corée du sud envisage de vendre les
actions qu'elle détient elle est en
effet en quête de liquidités compte tenu
de la situation dramatique du géant
naval stx corée je rappelle que la
france quant à elle est actionnaire à
hauteur de 33 3% par l'intermédiaire du
fonds stratégique d'investissement et
ceci depuis 2008 on peut donc aisément
mesurer le risque que cette vente
potentielle peut entraîner si nous ne
maîtrisons pas suffisamment leurs achats
le risque le plus important étant qu'un
financier de chantier concurrents
notamment européens se placent sur les
rangs nous privant par la suite de la
maîtrise de notre propre avenir
monsieur le ministre il est selon moi
deux logiques face à ces informations
qui ne cesse vous en doutez bien
d'inquiéter la première c'est une
logique industrielle en organisant à
l'initiative de l'état un tour de table
de grands groupes français afin qu'ils
réfléchissent rapidement un
positionnement offensif en termes de
rachat partiel ou total la seconde c'est
une logique de précaution qui n'exclut
pas par ailleurs la première
cette précaution c'est que la puissance
publique accepte momentanément d'être
majoritaire dans le capital afin de
maîtriser l'avenir d'une filière
industrielle qui fonctionne qui a su
innover et qui a su se diversifier
un paquebot de l'envergure du prochain
avec celui identique qui peut suivre ces
deux milliards d'euros dans notre
balance commerciale ce qui est loin
d'être négligeable dans la période que
nous traversons monsieur mini je vous
remercie de nous donner les informations
nécessaires
permettant je le souhaite de nous
rassurer sur le destin d'une filière
industrielle
indispensable à l'économie de notre be
je souhaite que la détermination du
gouvernement soit totale
merci monsieur benoit monde ministre
l'économie sociale et solidaire
la consommation monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur yannick vaugrenard
je voudrais adresser au nom du
gouvernement sur ce dossier qui
légitimement inquiète les élus que vous
êtes les familles et les salariés
du chantier de saint-nazaire un message
à la fois de confiance mais aussi de
vigilance de la part du gouvernement en
effet nous nous suivons avec la plus
grande attention les développements
actuels concernant la situation
financière du groupe coréen stx
ce dernier est actionnaire majoritaire d
stx europe qui lui-même détient plus de
66% des states france que se passe-t-il
aujourd'hui le groupe stx connaît des
difficultés financières est en cours de
redressement à l'initiative de la banque
publique coréenne kdb la question
l'option d'une cession de certains de
ses actifs notamment en europe est
aujourd'hui posée sans que pour autant
je tiens vous le dire le gouvernement et
été officiellement informé notifié de
ses attentions à ce jour l'état
actionnaire indirect de stx france via
bpi france n'a pas été saisie par stx
corée or aucun projet de cession ne peut
avoir lieu sans information préalable de
l'actionnaire public français plusieurs
points doivent donc être souligné en
aucun cas la situation économique et le
financement des chantiers de saint
nazaire ne sont en cause dans le
développement de la situation du groupe
stx corps et stx france al'inverse a
pleinement consolider son activité ces
derniers mois grâce à d'importants
contrats remportés en particulier à
l'export notamment comme vous l'avez
sites est monsieur le sénateur la
construction du plus grand paquebot de
croisière du monde oasis 3 l'activité de
saint nazaire n'est donc pas menacé par
les événements de corée le gouvernement
est pleinement mobilisé sur ce dossier
afin de conforter comme vous l'avez
souhaité parmi les options vous évoquer
l'avenir industriel des chantiers qu'il
continuera d'accompagner dans leur
développement et leur diversification
confiance donc dans l'avenir
capitalistique des chantiers et preuve
que le gouvernement suit avec la plus
grande attention la restructuration
actuelle du groupe coréen st le premier
ministre lui même a évoqué fin juillet
lors de son déplacement en corée cette
restructuration avec le premier ministre
coréen mais cette confiance nous empêche
pas la vigilance le principal enjeu
demeure pour nous comme pour vous
l'activité des chantiers plus que sa
structure actionnariale de quoi les
chantiers de saint nazaire ont-ils
besoin aujourd'hui d'abord comme vous
l'avez dit de continuer à engranger des
commandes pour continuer pour poursuivre
la consolidation des perspectives de
charge de travail ensuite de poursuivre
les actions visant à renforcer leur
compétitivité et à circonscrire
l'exposition de leurs activités un
nombre limité de commandes dans le
secteur de la croisière c'est le sens
des développements dans le domaine de
l'éolien offshore
ces aspects sont d'autant plus
importants que l'entreprise que les que
les questions actionnariale et d'un mot
conclure et là dessus monsieur le
président les temps au temps donc reste
un partenaire de long terme du groupe
aux côtés d'actionnaire industriel
responsable des heureux de développer la
société son activité et l'emploi merci
la parole à alain dufaut pour le groupe
ump
merci monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre délégué aux anciens
combattants
et sur le sujet qui nous intéresse et en
préambule je souhaiterais que nous
évitions les polémiques que les réponses
qui me seront apportés sortent du
sempiternel refrain
quand vous étiez au gouvernement je
souhaite également associer à ma
question
monsieur marcel pierre cléach président
du groupe des sénateurs anciens
combattants
alors monsieur le ministre le 24
septembre vous avez publié un décret en
plus tant de 20% la rente mutualiste du
combattant je rappelle qu a été créée en
s'il est impératif de réduire la dépense
publique
nous considérons que cela ne peut se
faire sur le dos de ceux qui ont
combattu pour la liberté et pour les
valeurs de la france
pour les anciens combattants et pour les
soldats engagés aujourd'hui en opex qui
sont les anciens combattants de demain
la rente mutualiste est plus qu'un
simple droit que l'on ne peut ajustés au
gré des impératifs budgétaires
c'est en effet un droit imprescriptible
une reconnaissance de la nation tout
entière pour leur engagement et leur
sacrifice sous le drapeau français
alors monsieur le ministre nous savons
que vous avez engagé des négociations
avec bercy et les principaux organismes
gestionnaires tels que la carac ou
france mutualiste
vous avez également annoncé à
l'assemblée nationale semaine dernière
la création d'un comité de suivi qui se
réunira annuellement afin d'examiner les
projections démographiques et
l'évolution des dépenses liées à
l'abondement de l'état afin de rétablir
éventuellement le taux normal de la
majoration
alors vous avez surtout annoncé que
cette mesure serait transitoire
nous pourrions bien le croire mais nous
ne sommes jamais trop prudent et nous
refaisons nous refusons solennellement
que ce futur comité soins palliatifs à
une réduction du tour de majoration de
rnc qui ferait en quelque sorte
jurisprudence
enfin et surtout
raboter le taux de majoration de la rmc
c'est s'attaquer au principe fondateur
de notre défense nationale c'est
s'attaquer au principe de l'égalité
entre les générations du feu et ça c'est
inacceptable pour toute la communauté de
la défense
alors monsieur le ministre à l'heure où
bon nombre de nos anciens combattants
vivent en dessous du seuil de pauvreté à
l'heure où les futurs anciens
combattants sont rentrés d'afghanistan
et se battent au mali pourriez-vous nous
dire aujourd'hui d'une manière précise
combien de temps va durer cette mesure
transitoire
merci madame najat vallaud-belkacem
ministre droits des femmes porte parole
du gouvernement
oui monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur du faux je n'ai aucune
intention de polémiquer avec vous sur ce
sujet important mais bien au contraire
de vous répondre avec précision et
peut-être avec un peu de pédagogie pour
que vous voyez plus clair sur les
intentions qui sont celles du ministre
en charge des anciens combattants
retenus par ailleurs et qui m'a chargé
de vous répondre comme vous le savez le
ministre kader arif s'est entretenu avec
les acteurs du système mutualiste un
dialogue enrichi s'en est ensuivi qui a
permis de dessiner des pistes pour
sécuriser les dispositifs fiscaux dont
bénéficient les anciens combattants et
de stabiliser en même temps la dépense
budgétaire afférentes à ce système
qu'en est il ressorti une baisse c'est
vrai mais très modeste de l'abondement
de l'état qui ne porte que sur la partie
spécifique et non pas sur la partie
légale de ces dispositifs mutualiste et
qui a permis plusieurs choses d'abord de
sécuriser la rente mutualiste comme un
dispositif qui relève du droit à
réparation ensuite de préserver la
double exonération fiscale à l'entrée et
à la sortie des rentes qui est le
principal avantage des rente mutualiste
de maintenir ensuite à 125 points pmi le
plafond de ses rentes de maintenir à
niveau constant le coût budgétaire de la
rente mutualiste hauteur aujourd'hui de
255 millions d'euros et enfin et je
crois que c'est un point que vous savez
important d'éviter toute remise en cause
de la demi part fiscale pour les veuves
d'anciens combattants
voilà ce à quoi aboutit cette
concertation que deux mutuelles
importante qui représente aujourd'hui
environ 60% des bénéficiaires ont salué
dans un communiqué publié le 10 octobre
dernier dix ans à la fois leur
satisfaction à l'égard de la
concertation qui a été conduite par le
ministre en charge des anciens
combattants mais aussi leur accord avec
la solution qui a été élaboré en toute
transparence
par ailleurs le ministre délégué aux
anciens combattants a souligné qu'une
commission de suivi serait mis en place
vous l'évoquez le but de cette
commission de suivi c'est de surveiller
précisément l'impact de cette mesure sur
les bénéficiaires de la rente est donc
une évaluation progressive sera menée
plus généralement pour
élargir le propos monsieur le sénateur
je veux souligner que dans un contexte
financier que nous savons tous
difficiles tout a été fait pour
préserver le budget des anciens
combattants il est à la baisse c'est
vrai 2,7 pour cent mais cette baisse est
inférieure de moitié à celle que la
précédente majorité à laquelle vous
appartenez lui avait imposée entre 2011
et 2012
5,4 pour cent de baisse à l'époque
cette préservation des moyens de ce
budget a permis quoi a permis de tenir
des promesses que vous même aviez prise
il ya de nombreuses années déjà sans
jamais les tenir je pense à trois choses
en particulier sur l'extension du droit
à la carte du combattant aux personnes
qui ont participé aux opérations
militaires en afrique du nord
l'accroissement de 6 % de l'aide sociale
de l'office national des anciens
combattants et enfin la meilleure prise
en charge des invalides mutilé grâce au
financement de prothèses nouvelle
génération je crois qu'on peut tous
élevés ici merci la parole à michel
saveur pour le groupe ump
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre de l'intérieur
monsieur le ministre
depuis votre arrivée place beauvau nous
sommes nombreux à adhérer à votre
discours particulièrement ferme et très
volontariste en matière de sécurité en
rappelant qu'il faut lutter contre les
phénomènes délinquants et mafieux
démanteler les trafics et combattre
l'exploitation de la misère qui s'y
greffent
mais ce qui paraît évident dans vos
discours les malheureusement moins au
niveau de vos résultats comme en atteste
le dernier bilan de l'observatoire
national de la délinquance et des
réponses pénales
alors je ne doute pas que vous aurez à
coeur de nous expliquer que les chiffres
manquent de fiabilité
reste que la plupart des indicateurs
sont à la hausse c'est particulièrement
vrai en zone jaune en brie ou sur les
douze derniers mois les cambriolages ont
augmenté de 12% et les violences aux
personnes de 10 4%
dans ce contexte
nos 100 mille gendarmes ont plus que
jamais besoin des moyens matériels
indispensables pour remplir efficacement
leurs missions or il éprouve
actuellement les plus grandes
difficultés à boucler leur budget 2013
lors de son audition devant la
commission de la défense de l'assemblée
nationale le 16 octobre dernier le
directeur général de la gendarmerie
nationale avait d'ailleurs attiré
l'attention sur les véritables
difficultés engendrées par un budget
sous tension
à titre de simple exemple le volume
d'essence disponible pour les trente
mille véhicules de gendarmerie est en
baisse de 6% par rapport à 2012 ces
restrictions portent également sur le
matériel informatique sur les véhicules
et les équipements nécessaires aux
militaires
autre sujet d'inquiétude
il serait aujourd'hui question pour la
direction de la gendarmerie nationale de
reporter le paiement des loyers dus aux
collectivités locales et ce pour
continuer d'assurer le bon
fonctionnement des unités
monsieur le ministre dans un contexte
économique et social difficile
les gendarmes sont notamment les
premiers exposés devant l'augmentation
de la délinquance il faut jour et nuit
un travail difficile et exigeant pour
garantir la sécurité de nos concitoyens
mais on ne peut pas leur demander plus
de résultats qui passe par une présence
accrue sur le terrain et dans le même
temps réduire leurs moyens
d'intervention aussi je vous remercie de
m'indiquer monsieur le ministre les
mesures que le gouvernement entend
prendre rapidement pour garantir les
crédits nécessaires au bon
fonctionnement de nos gens nos oreilles
merci monsieur manuel valls ministre
d'intérieur
ce président est monsieur le sénateur ça
va merci de l'attention que vous portez
à la situation de la gendarmerie
mais vous le savez
depuis six ans les crédits de
fonctionnement et d'investissement de la
gendarmerie ont baissé sous la majorité
que vous défendiez
de 18%
moi je regarde la réalité en face je
constate que depuis trente ans les
violences sur les personnes ne cessent
d'augmenter
près de 30% au cours de ces dernières
années je constate que l'explosion des
cambriolages est là depuis cinq ans et
ces derniers mois et ces violences et
ces cambriolages sauf dans les zones de
sécurité prioritaire ont augmenté et
donc nous devons ensemble parce que ce
sont des sujets difficiles nous attaquer
à ces phénomènes et pour cela nous avons
décidé d'arrêter l'hémorragie que la
police et la gendarmerie ont connu en
matière d'effectifs 6700 poste supprimé
dans la gendarmerie en cinq ans de
remplacer tous les départs à la retraite
et de créer tous les ans de 400 à 500
postes supplémentaires de policiers et
de gendarmes donc la priorité à la
sécurité c'est à la fois des moyens et
des hommes et les femmes en plus c'est
le choix du gouvernement et c'est la
priorité à la sécurité souhaitée par le
président de la république chaque année
des discussions ont lieu sur la fin de
gestion des budgets de l'état ne vont
pas échapper le général favier et eu
raison de souligner les difficultés qui
se posent à la gendarmerie a seulement
cette année mais au cours de ces
dernières années le premier ministre
vient de décider de dégeler 111 millions
de crédits de paiement pour la police et
la gendarmerie ainsi que 10 millions
d'autorisations d'engagement pour
répondre aux besoins immobiliers les
plus pressants dans la gendarmerie
nationale pour le logement des familles
et j'ai l'occasion de l'annoncé ce matin
lors de l'examen du budget sécu rité en
commission élargie à l'assemblée
nationale et j'ai le plaisir de le
rappeler ici même dans votre enceinte
cette décision du gouvernement aura une
conséquence très simple pour la première
fois mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
depuis 2007 les crédits exécuté par la
police nationale et la gendarmerie
nationale sont en augmentation par
rapport à l'année précédente de 2 % soit
40 millions c'est-à-dire dans un moment
difficile vous l'avez rappelé pour nos
finances publiques nous augmentons des
postes dans la police et dans la
gendarmerie et nous donnons en
fonctionnement et en investissement des
moyens supplémentaires à la gendarmerie
c'est vrai pour les brigades de
gendarmerie c'est vrai pour les forces
mobiles c'est vrai pôle parcs
automobiles de la gendarmerie c'est vrai
pour le carburant c'est vrai pour les
équipements informatiques pour nous la
priorité à la sécurité
ce ne sont pas des mots ce sont des
actes et nous les traduisons sur le
terrain
merci la parole est à présent à monsieur
richard tuheiava pour le groupe
socialiste et apparentés
le président mesdames et messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre chargé de l'économie sociale et
solidaire
et de la consommation
la loi du 25 décembre 2008 de finances
pour 2009 a institué entre l'article 67
le contrat de redynamisation des sites
de défense a dit crsd
afin d'ouvrir le droit pour l'état de
céder à l'euro symbolique certains
certains terrains militaires reconnu
inutile par le ministère de la défense
au profit des communes dans lesquelles
ces domaines fonciers sont situés le
décret d'application du 3 juillet 2009 à
fixer la liste des communes éligibles au
dispositif et pour la polynésie
française il s'agit des communes de arue
de farah de miley n'a pas pété pire un
poulain à hourriya de taiarapu ouest et
de teva i uta pour ce qui concerne
tahiti celle de rang et de tous les ja
aux îles tuamotu et celle de nuku hiva
aux marquises
ce dispositif a été approuvé à
l'unanimité des représentants élus à
l'assemblée de la polynésie française
depuis décembre 2011 et parle des
différents gouvernements locaux
successifs depuis d'ailleurs la plupart
des communes éligibles ont adopté des
délibérations aux conseils municipaux
pour approuver les projets de
reconversion qu'elle souhaitait engager
en depuis 2009 les communes
polynésiennes semblent être les seuls à
ne pas encore l'avoir bénéficier de ce
dispositif jusqu'à ce jour et devant une
telle situation
certes un certain nombre un certain
nombre de maires polynésiens ont
récemment annoncé vouloir passer à la
phase contentieuse ce qui me désole il
souhaite à cet égard légitime qu'un
dialogue direct puisse être envisagée à
paris avec les maires concernés des
lords qui vous en ferez la demande mais
c'est surtout une incompréhension de
fond sur le retard l'acquisition des
dires et militaires dans s'agit vraiment
deux années 60 et obéissez à une
décision politique le dispositif crsd de
2008 trouve encore sa source dans une
décision politique en 2008 c'est bien
une décision politique qu'attendent
aujourd'hui ces onze communes de poésie
française éligibles au dispositif crsd
dans le dénouement de cette affaire en
votant l'amendement du rapporteur de la
commission des finances d'ailleurs
créant un nouvel article 29 bis au
projet de loi de programmation militaire
2014 2019 le 21 octobre dernier eh bien
le scénario ouvert la voie à cette
solution politique et je l'en félicite
ainsi le délai d'expiration du
dispositif crsd repoussée au 31 décembre
2019 l'état des discussions récentes
entre le gouvernement et mes collègues
députés polynésiens tendrait à voir
encadré ce dispositif crsd à travers
l'outil du syndicat mixte mais une telle
solution technique n'offrent pas au
dispositif crsd monsieur le ministre un
cadre de gouvernance qui garantissent le
respect du principe de libre
administration de nos collectivités
locales car les tensions politiques
locales à des degrés variables
risquerait de s'envenimer toutefois
d'autres solutions pourraient être
trouvées à travers l'extension à ce
dispositif d' outils contractuels qui
ont déjà fait leur montre qu'elle sait
aussi mes chers collègues je termine
monsieur coli dont je veux parler du
contrat de ville mais aussi du contrat
urbain de cohésion sociale ma question
est donc la suivante quelle mesure le
gouvernement compte-t-il prendre pour
aboutir à un dénouement rapide et
concret du dispositif crsd en faveur des
communes éligibles de poésie française
je vous remercie merci monsieur veut
notamment les niçois jeunes économie
sociale et solidaire la consommation ce
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le sénateur richard
tout est à 20 d'abord j'avais omis de
d'excusés tout à l'heure
ministre de l'économie et des finances
je l'excusent à l'occasion de la réponse
au sénateur richard tuheiava vous avez
appelé l'attention du gouvernement sur
les sites de la situation des communes
de polynésie française qui quoique étant
éligibles au dispositif de cession à
l'euro symbolique n'ont pu acquérir les
emprises libéré par le ministère de la
défense dans le cadre de la loi de
programmation militaire 2009 2014
cette impossibilité résulte comme vous
le savez vous l'avez évoqué du contexte
institutionnel propre à la polynésie
française en application du statut
d'autonomie les communes ne peuvent
mobiliser leurs compétences aux fins de
mettre en oeuvre les projets
d'aménagement devant être réalisés sur
les sites concernés sauf dans le cadre
d'une loi de pays et de réglementation
polynésienne et sous réserve du
transfert des moyens nécessaires à l
inverse la collectivité de polynésie
française qui dispose des compétences
n'est pas éligible au dispositif de
cession à l'euro symbolique la
commission pour la transparence et la
qualité des opérations immobilières de
l'état organe garant du respect des
procédures en matière de cession
domaniale a été saisie du dossier par
deux fois cette commission composée de
membres des corps d'inspection et de
contrôle ainsi que des magistrats du
conseil d'état a invariablement rendu un
avis négatif motivé principalement par
la difficulté juridique que j'ai rappelé
la situation actuelle ne résulte pas
d'un blocage du gouvernement mais plutôt
d'un défaut du dispositif mis en place
par nos prédécesseurs qui ont omis de
prendre en compte les spécificités du
contexte institutionnel polynésiens et
les difficultés d'application qui en
résulterait le gouvernement partage je
vous le confirme votre volonté de
trouver une issue rapide à une situation
de manage dommageable pardon à la
polynésie française et à ses habitants
il va de soi que les engagements pris
par l'état au titre de l'accompagnement
des restructurations de défense doivent
être tenus en métropole comme dans les
outre-mers l'état soutient et soutiendra
les projets de redynamisation économique
des sites concernés et de construction
de logements sociaux c'est d'ailleurs
l'intérêt de l'état qui est propriétaire
de ces terrains la loi de programmation
militaire actuellement en discussion au
parlement prévoit explicitement la
prorogation du dispositif de cession de
l'euro symbolique jusqu'en 2019 vous
l'avez vous même rappelé
je vous confirme enfin que notre souhait
est de faire émerger avant l'expiration
du dispositif actuel une solution
juridiquement incontestable et qui
recueillerait l'assainissement des
collectivités je conclus pour vous dire
que les députés de polynésie ont à cet
égard évoqué la possibilité de
constituer des syndicats mixtes le
gouvernement est à l'écouté de cette
proposition et le haut commissaire a sur
un dialogue constant avec les
collectivités si d'autres schémas sont
proposées par les acteurs locaux
permettant de surmonter la difficulté
juridique à laquelle nous faisons face
collectivement le gouvernement est tout
naturellement prêts à l'examiner avec
vous et l'ensemble des acteurs concernés
je vous remercie
merci monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues nous en avons fini avec des
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
je vais suspendre la séance elle sera
reprise à 16h15 pour la suite de la
discussion du projet de loi garantissant
l'avenir la justice du système des
retraites la séance est suspendue
voilà vous avez pu suivre les questions
d'actualité au sénat et nous tout de
suite et bien aux débris forfait la
séance
bienvenue donc sur public sénat pour on
refait la séance on va refaire toutes
les questions d'actualité les questions
parlementaires mais aussi les questions
politiques je salue le sénateur patriat
françois patriat qui est avec nos bons
jours son chanteur de côte-d'or avec
vous évidemment parler de la bretagne et
najat vallaud belkacem la porte parole
du gouvernement et bien s'est exprimé
sur l'écotaxe et ce qui se passe en
bretagne vous propose de l'écouter puis
on doit pas juste après bien ce projet
qui avait été votée en 2009 conçu par
l'ancienne majorité
préparé par l'ancien gouvernement dans
la mise en oeuvre avait déjà été reporté
une fois preuve des difficultés qu'elles
posent et chacun sait ici que l'écotaxe
n'est pas la cause de la crise de
l'agroalimentaire en bretagne mais
indéniablement elle soulève des
questions de mise en oeuvre qui n'ont
pas été anticipées par le gouvernement
précédent alors le gouvernement actuel a
déjà à corriger certains effets négatifs
de cette écotaxe mais à l'évidence ça
n'était pas suffisant c'est la raison
pour laquelle le premier ministre a
choisi de recréer les conditions d'un
dialogue constructif dans la région en
suspendant la mise en oeuvre de cette
écotaxe ce dialogue mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs il devra
associer toutes les bonnes volontés je
sais qu'elles sont nombreuses je vous
remercie monsieur le sénateur d'en faire
partie françois patriat vous avez
demandé un moratoire sur l'écotaxe il ya
une suspension ça a été annoncé par le
premier ministre est ce que vous êtes
satisfait vous vouliez aller beaucoup
plus loin que la suspension je crois que
le gouvernement a fait preuve au
l'occurrence à la fois 2 le réalisme de
lucidité de responsabilité mais vous
vous demandiez un moratoire je vraiment
des jeux demandait un moratoire à partir
du moment où un processus était
déclenchée qui vivait à ce que certains
territoires soient traités de façon
différente alors que beaucoup de
territoires en france connaît des
difficultés économiques importantes
pense à la région bourgogne qui a perdu
26 mille emplois en deux ans 6 10 8 %
des emplois le double de la moyenne
française et qui aujourd'hui avec des
autoroutes à péage payant plus l'écotaxe
de masse il devait la payer donc ce que
j'ai demandé au gouvernement c'est de
faire en sorte que soit entendu la voix
des territoires qu'ils disent cette
écotaxe telle actifs voté par vernement
par une majorité est souvent d'ailleurs
avec l'assentiment général dans un
contexte économique était différent le
contexte économique a changé il faut en
tenir compte pour l'application les
portiques ont été construits c'est
certain et les portiques sont enlevés
aujourd'hui et les postic celui tombé
aujourd'hui parce qu'il vaut mieux le d
le démonter adroitement que de laisser
détruits dans une manifestation
éventuelle mais je crois que quand même
à 6 ans françois patriat ça veut dire
que finalement c'est peut-être la faute
de cette écotaxe calcul à l'abandon la
mort dont je ne saurais le croire je ne
saurais le dire c'est pas ce qu'a dit le
gouvernement c'est parce que j'ai
demandé pour ce qui me concerne moi j'ai
demandé un moratoire moratoire jusqu'à
ce que la croissance soit là que les
conditions économiques pour les
entreprises qu'elles soient
industrielles artisanales ou agricoles
soit en mesure de l'assumer et vous
entendez ce que dit la droite notamment
ils disent 800 millions us au milieu il
va falloir trouver 800 millions pour
compenser finalement cette suspension
j'ai dû compenser ces 800 millions et
les recettes mais il ya aussi ce qu'on
doit verser à une société pour lequel
une commission d' enquête va être créé
au sénat si aujourd'hui était italienne
qui s'appelle ecomouv tout à fait mais
sur le manque à gagner est attendu c'est
pour les départements que ça va être
difficile demain qui ont en
responsabilité les routes et pour l'état
aussi je le comprends bien mais il ya un
moment où on peut suspendre quelques
investissements parce qu'on ne peut pas
dans le même temps mettre à mal des
entreprises connaît déjà de graves
difficultés donc je crois que c'est une
solution de sagesse et lucidité le
président du groupe socialiste au sénat
françois rebsamen demande une commission
d enquête sur cette société italienne
vous êtes d'accord avec lui oui je pense
que vous voir les conditions dans
lesquelles ce marché qui me paraît ce
contrat inclut leona a été passé compte
tenu de rapports qu'il est entre le coot
et puis la ressource je sais très bien
vous avez un discours de vérité je
voudrais vous parler d'autre chose je
voudrais vous parler il ya des cotes de
popularité du président de la république
et du premier ministre qu'est ce que
vous en pensez aujourd'hui le descend il
descend presque 27% selon un dernier
sondage pour le figaro magazine c'est
très bas pour un président de la
république jusqu'où peut-il aller
comment peut-il gouverner aujourd'hui en
temps de crise
quand on prend des mesures courageuses
pas anormal d'être impopulaire si la
popularité elle est la rançon d'un cap
qui est clair